-So, I wanna ask you
about this --
In the wake
of Tara Reade's allegation
against Joe Biden,
you wrote a really beautifully
written post on Medium,
that I recommend
everybody check out.
You talked about being a sexua
assault survivor, yourself
and how survivors' justice
is a really hard thing
to achieve.
How do you think moments
like this need to be addressed
regardless of political party?
-Well, they have to be
addressed in good faith
and I have to, you know,
just point out the fact
that I think many
who are offering commentar
in the discourse are not
doing that in good faith.
They don't care about survivors'
healing and justice.
They don't care
about due process.
You know, they're doing
what people have done
for far too long,
and that is to take this issue
to take my survivor community,
and use people as politica
fodder and footballs.
These are the same people
that vote consistently
against the Violence Against
Women Act authorization,
which is still sitting on th
desk of Mitch McConnell.
So, we have to operate
in good faith.
We have been to be
good faith partners.
We have to be willing
to have hard conversations
I think we have not
gotten this right,
as a society, as lawmakers
as a culture,
and this is an opportunity
through partnership
and hard conversations,
to get there.
-You were recently honored
as Villain of the Week
on Fox News.
-[ Scoff ]
-Is that
[ Laughing ] something tha
you take as a point of pride
when something
like that happens?
-Let me brush my shoulder.
[ Laughter ]
So let me just say this.
I'm so proud
of our daughter Cora.
She recently earned straight
"A's"; and, in fact, two "A+",
one in Spanish
and one in science.
And, you know, we printed it out
and we put it up, you know
on our family sort of wall
bulletin board
and I did the same thing
when that came out.
If Fox is calling me
the Villain of the Week,
that is really only evidence
that I'm being
the woman
my mother raised me to be
and that I am advancing
progressive values
and making people uncomfortabl
in the pursuit of progress
and I am perfectly fine
with that.
So, judge me
by my enemies, please.
-Congresswoman,
thank you so much
for making the time
for us today.
It was a delight to talk to yo
and keep up the good work.